[Music]
let's go to leslie in burlington coat
factory vermont what's up leslie how we
doing
good morning dr john how are you this
morning so good how about you
i'm doing very well the sun is shining
life is good
yes
we are out here our pets heads are
falling off what's up how can i help
i'm doing uh so i was looking for some
advice on how to handle some family
relationships in particular the one with
my sister okay some of the context is
that
i recently got married last month and i
had been with my now husband for just
about six years
early on there was some conflict between
him and my family because he has some
strong conservative values and very
strong convictions in his faith and they
sort of attacked him for that
my parents and most of my extended
family seeing that i was happy were able
to look past it and just see him for the
guy that he is
but some and some of my family in
particular my sister and a few cousins
who i was very close with before i
started dating him are sort of still
holding on to that
um
not quite resentment but you know for
lack of a better word resentment um
it's now to the point where like
my sister won't talk to me refuses to
visit our house and essentially causes
drama any chance that she get
any chances she gets if i'm being honest
there have i've never really had a good
relationship with my sister but it's
definitely gone exponentially worse
since i started dating my husband
um i i don't want to assume any motive
but if i had to put my guess
i would think that it's partially
because my husband really helped me find
out you know what my beliefs were and
let me do my own
you know investigating and for my
forming my own opinions instead of just
you know whatever my family pushes me
into whatever box they assigned me to
sure um what can i do to help rebuild
and in some cases build
these relationships back without having
to cave on my views and beliefs uh you
can't
um easy enough yeah
so i mean you dated this guy for six
years and you knew
what your family thought of them
and you knew you thought of him and you
chose him
and so
as a result of your choice
your family is now making their choices
and the challenge here is everybody's
got a
fantasy that they're trying to uphold
like i think in your heart and mind that
once they realize that no i really love
him and yes we see the world differently
but he's a good guy i'm a good person
and and and
then we'll all just go back to one big
happy family like on the tv shows
and they thought
oh we can't stand his beliefs and values
and he's annoying he's got a whatever
and whatever and fill in the blank
but once once they get married they'll
just be fine and then everybody realized
it was exactly the same as before you're
married
and there so the fantasy is crumbling in
front of everybody and then people
respond to crumbling fantasies in
different ways
i tend to respond to them with a moment
of frustration and then just like i
don't know i i don't know if it's
genetic or what i just move on like
you know jocko he says like good like it
is what it is man let's just move on to
the next thing other people spend the
next 40 years of their life
going to war over their picture of that
fantasy what our life should have been
and it doesn't feel right it doesn't
look right so it's your fault and it's
their fault and i'm going to create
drama and whatever
so really the thing you can do is treat
your sister with dignity and respect and
move on about your day because she's
chosen to not be in a relationship with
you anymore because you chose to be in a
relationship with your husband right i
mean so it's just like a
as he said she said she said he said
i think you need to grieve the fact that
your family's opting out of you
is that hard
incredibly yeah it sucks huh
big time
like is what i'm saying resonating with
you
or am i out to lunch
no definitely definitely um it feels
like you've been holding your breath for
the last four or five years trying to
trying to make them all happy
and still love this guy
and truly become who you are in this
moment and you're by the way i think
every single person's beliefs should
change over time
that's why we read new books and
go to speeches and try new workout
programs and
create discipline in our lives so that
we learn new things and our beliefs
change but i think our values should
stay the same
meaning i will treat people with dignity
and respect i will honor my body and my
family blah blah so
right now your beliefs are what they are
and you've chosen them good for you i'm
proud of you for having resolve and for
strength and that you've worked them out
on your own and with somebody who you
care about great it just sucks when our
family looks at our values and who we
want to become and they're like uh i opt
out that's hard right
for sure and um
sort of what like
you know since i started dating him it's
definitely felt like i'm more of like
the black sheep of the family like my
cousin like like i said before i used to
be
very close to my cousins and now they
all have
a group chat without me
and
they
you know make plans without me even if
it's in my area and
i guess what was the kicker and kind of
led to all this kind of like
drama starting was
when my sister had
you know i had invited my sister up said
come up for dinner like let's talk this
all out
you know start fresh like let's play
everything on the table and she's like i
can't i'm busy
blah blah and then then that weekend she
had driven two hours past me to go on a
spontaneous adventure
and that just makes me think like okay
so you have time
to drive past me
to do this spontaneously
okay let's just say it loud she doesn't
like you
that's fair
yeah it sucks it's hard but let's just
face that truth she doesn't like you she
doesn't want to be around you
so much so that she'll lie to you her
own sister
so much so that she will drive past your
house to go be with other people
and i think you need to spend some time
living in that reality
and if i was to be meeting with your
cousins right now on the phone if there
was like six of them all on the phone
calling me you know what they'd be
saying
we told her for five years and she chose
him over us and we're hurt by that
right and that's what you did and i'm
not saying that's right or wrong i'm
just trying to lay out the facts of this
thing
for sure so everybody's made their
choices they're big grown-up decisions
and
they've led everybody to
a place where they don't want to be in
relationship with each other
you want the idea of a sister
but you don't like your sister you
haven't ever
is that
right
just putting it a bit strongly but in so
many words
okay yeah i mean you like the idea of
having a like ride or die sister that
you call and you talk about things and
when you get pregnant you're gonna talk
about that and
when your husband does something dumb
you got somebody and that's just not
going to be your situation at least for
the time being
what i do think often these value
conversations
turn into
you're a scumbag
and underneath values conversations
especially political conversations
whether it's conservative or liberal
conversation and we just force the world
into these two options which is just so
stupid
um
it
can be values based but then it gets
into
hospitality base and that's where i
think both sides have issues
right i hate your idea so much i won't
be in your physical presence and i think
that's that's toxic and insane
and
i hate this group of people or this way
of thinking or this way of being this
way of acting so much
i'm gonna cash out my family over it and
i think that's insane too
i think there's a third way
right but that's not where your family
is that's not where a lot of families
are and that's okay
um i think you've got to sit in the
reality
that your family doesn't want to be
around you
and and i'm not saying that trite i'm
seeing that with a broken heart for you
and then when you grieve that so all
grief is is the gap between what i
expected and hoped for
and reality that's grief i thought he
would live forever i thought she would
quit drinking i thought that he would
only cheat on me one time but he's done
it three times that
grief is just sitting in that gap for a
minute and then saying now what
and then now what will mean you still
have to have people in your life and so
you're gonna have to be about making new
friends people you can call and trust
and lean into
you're gonna have to be about
reimagining what holidays are gonna look
like
you're gonna have to be about
reimagining what your relationship with
your sister's gonna be because you're
still gonna have to deal with mom and
dad you're still gonna they're getting
older all that kind of stuff you're
still gonna have to have a communication
even if it's just quick text messages or
emails or whatever but that's not for
right now right now it's just sitting in
the grief
your sister
thinks you chose him over them
and now they're moving on with their
life without you
i'm sorry
no it's definitely a good way to put it
and um
i guess what's made this also
hard is that
my mom definitely tends to like
not put her problems on me but like
looks to me to
essentially solve her problems and this
has definitely been
a
big point of contention for her because
she wants me of course she does happy
family like everyone does and it's just
so here's how you can handle that
you can tell your mom mom i love you and
i now have come to a place to realize um
i'm married who i married
i'm gonna stay with him
i
right now believe the way i believe
and i'm gonna continue to be a searcher
continue to
look for um ways i can grow and learn as
we work through the world and that might
make you more conservative infinitely
more conservative i'm not trying to lean
you in a certain way saying this is just
who i am i'm going to be somebody who's
always looking and
learning and asking questions and
meeting with new people but this is this
is our life i love you
i will always show up for dinner i'll
always be there
i'm not gonna go to war with my family
and if y'all choose other things without
me that's that hurts my feelings it
breaks my heart i'm gonna choose to
allow that to break my heart and i
understand y'all are grown ups younger
to make those calls but i think it's
also fair after you grieve what what
comes after grief is boundaries
and after you lose a spouse you have to
decide what i will watch and what i will
look at and who i will hang out with
like you've gotta really start to
create new boundaries that's where
you're gonna be
and you and your husband will co-create
those boundaries together we're just i'm
not i'm gonna quit reaching out to
sister other than on her birthday i'm
gonna send her something because i'm a
decent human being i am going to send
her a text on her birthday i am going to
i i'll do i'll be human
um but i'm going to start doing the hard
work of finding new friends and that's
hard
i'm going to do the hard work of
controlling my thoughts and actions and
if she chooses to i'm not going to put
her into a situation even light him
anymore i'm going to move on from that
and i'm going to tell my mom mom i can't
solve all your problems i will be there
for dinner and if you ask him to not
come i'm not going to come and because
you're putting me in a situation that um
i i'm not i'm not gonna be i'm not gonna
play along with
but yeah you gotta spend some time with
some grief is hard you can't make people
like you and after six years you made
your choice and again i'm proud of your
convictions i'm proud of your strength
and now you made your choices and then
we're gonna live in the reality of what
those choices mean for you and for those
that you care about
i know it's hard
but we'll be with you
you